welcome to this ups and up the King back
to this video playing copy 45 from Italy
let's see what we got
four nights with g3 so called like a
variation played a lot by Igor Glick
former Russian now German Grandmaster a
six in age six this is what like is
normally doing preventing the pin here
and also making sure that the bishop has
got some Retief retreats clasp to a semi
a farts slightly slightly surprising
this move not quite sure what the ideas
you know I have some many ideas I can
Castle short I can also try something
something wire them with the g5 him
maybe g5 how ridiculous is it
I mean a4 is a move that actually makes
me consider to castlelong as something
that before b5 is less likely to happen
okay let's uh let's gamble a bit here
with this not sure how good it is but it
is a bit more interesting than castling
short yeah I feel he should play Bishop
III him trying to get rid of the c5
bishop we have an interesting situation
now I can I can just trade it or think
about something else
can also allow him to take and it's not
particularly bad but he might play d4
them and they might play deform okay 94
is really not good
so I'm going to take it yeah the
question is is there default coming on
or not probably it is coming
should I play d5 myself this is a maybe
not a bad solution yeah let's break
let's break in the center first DD 95
this looks this looks Fatih okay good
have a good position in the center and
he's
some some weaknesses here like III and
g3 or quickly played but it makes this
Bishop really bad
not sure that that ephors is great he
might want to play C 3 and C 3 before
those kind of things maybe I can't play
94 get rid of the Knights that I'm not
sure about but okay I need to speed up a
bit
b3 is a it's a surprising move and lets
me easily block on the dark squares not
Queen a7 please don't want to want to
allow that he could play H or maybe h4
Bishop h3 he tried you trying to do
something for his bed for sure but he
does not does not seem to want to go for
this okay rope d6 is a good
multi-purpose move mostly preparing loop
c6 of course now that's just a very
comfortable position what has no counter
play whatsoever
yeah that's an interesting spot I was
thinking that even g5 is Olivia to know
it's a good move maybe it's it's
weakening f6 but it makes sure that he
does not get his very bad bishop traded
with g4 maybe coming from my side in
killing his bishop of course f6 is a
weakness but I hope that this is not so
not so important maybe it is now then I
look at it hmm
now this and I this was a bad idea could
have also just taken on h4
Queen f6 is coming now Rhys was a [ __ ]
and made the typical mistake of playing
too quickly by far too quickly
yeah I know it looks terribly passive
but I need to need to protect my working
site in its otherwise I'm simply toast
Queen f6 and it takes it well this was a
very bad play by me not amazing what I
did there if I get rid of the Queen's
it's it's okay but oh well that's very
good that's very accommodating no
everything's fine again I can know and
try to get the King over trying to yeah
this is just a demonstration the ruckus
is far less threatening here then the
Queen my bishop only six is keeping
stuff together okay how do I continue
here probably fixing fixing those pawns
okay no it's not threatening look f6 so
I can prevent this I would like to get
one time right exchange
let's let's see if I can manage that yep
I should have played Bishop to e6 first
I try
we trade everything off King this
success the ending okay this is not I
have Bishop e6 and and Jack Jack 30s
Bishop f1 to see form unfortunately and
this King and pawn and Kim is probably
nothing it was a very very badly played
by me yeah I didn't want to go down what
did i do them very weird pre move but
okay don't have any time
check you know nothing nothing happening
already Gras our third Quran is this a
draw actually now that I think of it I
mean I didn't have any to any time to to
really consider listen to winning yeah
of course yeah this I just played it
really badly here around here um why
this is in really bad shape I just need
to be more precise here the problem is
he's got all the parts on oops on light
squares here all those pawns and white
he should and widely yeah probably
shouldn't lose I should be able to to to
really yeah to challenge him in a way a
bit and not I played it really badly
maybe I shouldn't exchange rooks I'm I
thought it would be a good idea this is
a bad move them should play this to have
an eye on the b3 pawn my dream scenario
of course is sorry about that
it's the the King invasion all the way
here this would be fantastic
yeah but okay this is obviously very
solid I mean he also has deformed that
that's a big big problem in terms of
that maybe maybe dt4 it's not really
possible here I can play something like
that after that d4 is it's not a great
idea check and this is going to get ugly
so yeah but okay I have a hard time to
get the King over and I cannot really
make any any sort of headway without the
king heading over to before okay this is
this is very dry still okay interesting
maybe I shouldn't play the rook trade
then yeah probably so that's a bet it's
a bad idea to trade the rooks this is
much better I'm putting here and then
this is actually very clear advantage
from black computer is on minus one
already yeah which is not surprising bad
idea
to exchange rooks yeah my positional
sense was really off them and also I
made a huge mistake
here in this position with pushing g5 at
it is interesting an interesting idea to
kill his bishop but on the other hand as
you see the whole Queens are air King
Cyrus is totally weakened and he always
has this invasion ideas it wasn't a
great idea
I probably after h4 I mean I can't just
play a move like that and continue from
here it is slightly more comfortable for
me because of this bad pawn structure
you know I have the better point
structure in relation to my bishop and
c2 is weak and so on it's nothing that
should lead to a forced we know anything
but I can definitely try a bit okay
thanks for watching